lo que vamos a hacer ahora es encontrar
las diferencias entre conjuntos para
esto empezaremos con el conjunto a el
cual ya lo he descrito deja de ponerlo
con el mismo verde y en ambos casos he
considerado conjuntos de números podría
haber tomado países podría haber tomado
personas o de haber tomado animales pero
decidí usar números para mantener las
cosas simples
empezaremos entonces con el conjunto a
ya este conjunto le restamos el conjunto
b es decir estamos encontrando la
diferencia entre el conjunto a y el
conjunto b y esta diferencia va a
determinar un conjunto el conjunto de
elementos que están en el conjunto a
pero que no están en el conjunto b
consideremos entonces que es lo que está
en el conjunto a y que no está en el
conjunto b
eso significa que tomemos el conjunto a
y le quitemos el 17 el 19 más bien los
17 los 19 y los 6 es y que resulta
entonces vamos a tener el 5
el 3 el 17 no lo vamos a incluir porque
el 17 está en el conjunto b y tenemos
que quitar los elementos que están en ay
que están en b entonces lo incluimos el
17 si vamos a incluir el 12 que no está
en b y no vamos a incluir el 19 pues
está en b excluimos el 19 y tenemos
entonces este conjunto que resulta de
restar el conjunto b al conjunto a como
mencionamos entonces una manera de ver
esto es como el conjunto de elementos
que están en el conjunto a y que no
están en el conjunto b o puedes verlo
como el conjunto de elementos que no
están en el conjunto b pero están en el
conjunto a déjame aclarar esto esto lo
puedes ver como ve restado el conjunto b
restado del conjunto a o también puedes
verlo como el complemento
el complemento tengo a veces problemas
con la fotografía el complemento
relativo el complemento relativo del
conjunto ve en el conjunto a y ya
hablaremos más de complemento en un
futuro pero el complemento debe es el
conjunto de elementos que no están en
vez y cuáles son todos esos elementos
que no están en be complemento debe
elementos que no en be pero sí en a
entonces cuando consideramos el
complemento debe estaremos pensando en
todos los números que no son ni el 17 y
el 19 ni el 6 o más aún considerando
esto en un sentido más amplio
considerando todo lo que no está en b no
veo una naranja en b no veo un caballo
en b
en fin tomando un universo más amplio
todo lo que no está en be es el
complemento de b pero aquí queremos lo
que no está en be pero si está en el
conjunto a que son los números 5 3 y 12
ahora cuando ves esto como ve restado de
a dices bueno ok yo reste el 10
este también el 19 de pero qué pasa con
el número 6 no puede restar el número 6
digo si estuviéramos hablando del número
2 quizás acabaríamos con un número menos
seis cuando restas un conjunto de otro
si el elemento que estás considerando no
está en el conjunto original entonces
éste no cambia si intentó eliminar todos
los seises del conjunto a no va a
cambiar no hay ceses para empezar es
como si sea eliminar todos los caballos
del conjunto a no va a cambiar nuestra
manera de notar la diferencia de a&b o
el complemento relativo de b en a es la
anotación que va a poner a continuación
tendríamos
y este símbolo que es como la división
invertida este símbolo de la división
invertida lo cual significa la
diferencia entre el conjunto y el
conjunto b cuando escribimos esto
estamos considerando el conjunto de
elementos que están en a pero que no
están en b o el conjunto que resulta
extraer los elementos debe del conjunto
a o el complemento relativo debe en a
con esto en mente consideremos entonces
el problema inverso que sería entonces
en b es las que voy a llamar a esto es
las b es las a o la diferencia debe
menos
y esto lo podemos escribir como esto es
igual a b
menos
a que es igual este conjunto bien de
acuerdo a lo que hemos dicho esto
podemos verlo como el conjunto b al cual
le quitamos los elementos del conjunto a
o también podemos verlo como el
complemento de a que se encuentra en el
conjunto b pensémoslo como el conjunto b
al cual extraemos los elementos de a
veamos entonces tenemos un 17 en b pero
también tenemos un 17 en el conjunto a
así es que extraemos el 17 tenemos un 19
pero también hay un 19 nada lo extraemos
tenemos un 6 en b no tenemos 6 en nada
así es que nos quedamos tan solo con el
elemento 6 6 es el único elemento de
este conjunto b menos a un ejemplo más
que resulta del complemento relativo de
a en a esto es igual esto es igual a la
diferencia de a menos y esto como lo
vamos a calcular bueno vamos a extraer
los elementos del conjunto a de a
tenemos el elemento 5 de a pero éste
también está en lo eliminamos el
elemento 3 que también está en a lo
eliminamos también lo mismo sucede con
los demás elementos por lo cual nos
resulta el conjunto vacío el conjunto
vacío
el conjunto vacío que también se designa
con la letra griega fi también
denominado conjunto nulo conjunto nulo o
conjunto vacío aquel conjunto que no
tiene elementos